I'm so curious as to what the princess
and karapika are doing right now as we
head over to them again next chapter so
yeah in case you didn't know it is
confirmed that karapika is going to
appear in chapter 400. tagashi actually
spoiled this close to five months ago
now by posting the final panel of
chapter 400 on Twitter and would you
look at that it's our favorite blonde
mop head and this feels like it's been a
long time coming like I expected this
batch to pick up with the mafia stuff
because well because that's where we
left off but man have I been craving to
head back up to Tier 1 and catch up with
the actual succession War it's easy to
forget but tensions are seriously
boiling on tier one right now because we
have the death game within a death game
currently happening involving silent
majority and the Mystery of exactly who
that their ability belongs to so it
looks like we'll be getting one last
troop Focus chapter with chapter 400
because the text at the end of 399 says
that next time the troop will pursue the
Haley but then it also says that the
princes are on the move so I suspect
we'll be cutting back to Tier 1 for the
next set of chapters and I suppose that
the upper and the lower stories are
going to kind of play out in tandem late
frogging between the two and maybe when
both of them are at maximum chaos
they'll eventually Collide but for now
I'm just preparing myself to hold to try
and remember the names of all of the
bodyguards and the maids and all of the
other people that just haven't been
relevant in my life for the last three
years all I know right now is that I'm
pretty damn hyped to see karapika and
hey if hisoka did follow Henry's
proposal and take a trip to tier one
then we might even see him interacting
in the next batch as well which I think
would start to make things feel more
like classic Hunter again Nobunaga
didn't seem phased when he lost his
blade maybe he could use his order as a
sword I mean almost certainly in fact
gone did exactly that when he developed
his scissors ability transmuting his
Aura to take on the properties of an end
blade and my general rule is that if
gone can do it then so can every other
enhancer because most of them are
actually better than him other options
are definitely available to create sharp
objects though I mean when introducing
the very concept of Nan one of the First
Things wing does is sharpen paper via
enhancement to turn it into a blade and
even remote is a good example of this
using enhancement to turn his own
feathers into blades so blade-based
weapons and techniques are very much
enhancement 101 however my question
would be whether or not nobunaka would
actually want to use his Aura in that
sort of way nobunaga's skill set is so
closely tied to a physical blade and in
particular he practices the idol which
is a martial art that focuses on quick
drawing one's blade from the sheath so I
don't think that it would be anywhere
near as simple to replicate this very
specific tool that he requires for this
I'd love it if you could clarify how
Nobunaga and Henry were evicted I can
absolutely do that because it is
slightly confusing tagashi used diagrams
in the last chapter for a very good
reason but luckily Reddit Denizen Uber
fate was able to create a very simple
and easy to understand diagram Nobunaga
and Henry were evicted because the
nengards actually dragged them into what
is labeled here as the Haley living room
that doorway was rigged with one of the
kante's teleportation landmines which
plonked our Duo back into room 3101 that
room itself having another teleportation
landmine at the doorway which will
transfer people to what is labeled here
as the shower room and you can see how
the loop works from there very
importantly both doorway abilities only
trigger when someone enters the room not
when they exit so there's a bit of a
confusing irony at play here whereby to
kick someone out you actually need to
bring them in but also we now know where
two of the landmines are and at most
there could be three which Nobunaga does
speculate on at the end he says there's
probably a special jump point for
members only I also think we should
clarify one thing about Henry I've seen
some discussions centered on the absence
of his ever reliable pigeons and why he
didn't just fly some into the room but
there's actually quite a few reasons why
the biggest of which being that if Henry
did the pigeons probably would have been
teleported because they're living things
and as far as we know only objects can
pass through so this ability is just a
flat out counter to Henry who can only
create living things but also because
Henry is well he's all tuckered out
after making an oyster a cat two snake
guns and a multitude of pigeons he's
running a little low on Aura so in the
past 10 chapters that means we've pretty
much seen the full scope of what Henry
is capable of quantity wise not creative
wise that is unlimited and I think he
did a pretty a good job all things
considering I can't help it feel this
chapter was super weird it seemed like
they basically knew the troop was coming
but only prepared to have them kicked
out of there I can't help but feel like
they had ample opportunity to score
juicy 20 levels hmm juicy so it's one
thing to know that your enemy is coming
but it's completely another thing to to
actually be able to do something about
it with that knowledge and this is all
likely to do with Morena one of the
family members I think it was souffle
flat out stated that they were ordered
not to engage with Nobunaga and Henry
which I suspect came from Morena who
knew full well that a head-on fight
would only result in a third of her
family's heads decapitated on the floor
because there's there's a lot of people
in this room so many people but remember
this of the four nen uses we saw all of
them were defensive the gods that damage
transfer the implied healing and the
block none of those abilities were
suited to take down Henry or Nobunaga
furthermore there's also three people in
this room who don't actually have
abilities yet because they're still too
low level gelato chiffon and Mont Blanc
if I'm identifying them correctly but
then going back back to the
teleportation diagram there's no actual
way for these two parties to actually
engage Nobunaga and Henry can't get into
the room because they'll get zipped and
if the Haley members exit the living
room then they can't Retreat back into
it or else they'll be teleported so
thinking about this in terms of all
sorts of positionings it would be a
massive disadvantage for any of them to
leave the living room and given that
none of them are actually suited to
punch fight anyway in retrospect
conflict was just never an option right
now Morena is playing very defensively
all of her attacking pieces like Dogman
seem to be elsewhere slowly leveling up
and becoming Stronger Just patiently
waiting until Miranda knows that she has
the power to actually take on nen users
of this sort of high level did the
activation of ability most attack imply
that Moreno was somewhere in The Hideout
it doesn't just imply it it actually
flat out confirms it Morena is here not
here imarona is there and so that creepy
panel that we saw of her in chapter 398
wasn't just for fun atmosphere and
aesthetic Flair she is very close and
likely monitoring everything that just
happened probably from her very comfort
looking game at you thinking about her
role as the game master a bit more she's
likely going to be taking on a more
stationary position observing and
facilitating the game as opposed to
getting too involved herself despite the
fact that she technically is a player
and does have her own levels but she
seems to have set up a pretty amazing
defense in fact I would say she's
actually currently harder to reach than
like half the princes how many minutes
do I put for popcorn in the microwave
Depends for example if it's ready-made
popcorn then you'd put it in for zero
minutes I think some are giving Haley
family too much credit if we swapped
Nobunaga for Franklin they would have
been wiped out their abilities are way
too specific so I touched on this in the
chapter review but even I didn't quite
Express just the massive scope of how
true it is the Haley family got so damn
lucky because as stated if this was
Franklin he would have given them all
just a merciless fingery death but also
Machi ilumi kalato and even banolanov
would have been instant bloodbaths the
funny thing with banolinov in particular
is that he really could have taken his
time to summon because yokitani's Gods
would have needed him to commit a crime
before being able to evict him so again
the Haley family got very complacent
here but lucky for them they won this
dice roll and I suppose what this means
is that everyone in this room is now
much more experienced as a result they
survived this mistake and won't make it
again do we know the deal with the 22
disciples professions like are those
part of the death game or were they
their jobs before they overthrew the
previous family leadership just
something I've been wondering so these
are very easy to overlook because
Togashi has this tendency to just
bombard us with information but when the
Haley family members are each introduced
we get three pieces of information or if
you include the names I'm not three
pieces we get their player level we get
their net Affinity if they have one yet
and we get their former profession and
this is relevant because the eventual
none abilities often tie directly into
that profession the obvious example
being yokotani who was a quote
unscrupulous lawyer and so he has an
ability based on a very subjectively
applied concept of Law and Order
featuring toy robots for for a reason a
lot of the Haley family have what I'm
going to refer to as a bit of a dodgy
profession like being former Mafia
Hitman Transporters disposal Etc like
there's a lot of Mafia roles it's almost
like playing town of Salem and that
makes sense because these disciples are
all implied to have been members of the
Hailey family before Miranda took over
these were the 22 chosen that kill
slaughtered the rest of the family
although with that said some of them do
have interesting professions such as
gelato who is a Pro Gamer or my favorite
member Dogman who is a pro wrestler
emission needs enough but such a cool
category that's unexplored yes so the
last 10 chapters and togashi's memo
especially have now turned a mission
into this new OP category and I think
it's about time because emission in the
series so far is criminally
underexplored I imagine a big part of
that was because Leorio was the
protagonist chosen to Showcase a mission
which becomes very problematic when
Togashi then chooses not to Showcase
Leorio you've got gone killer and
krapika who cover enhancement
transmutation and contraration illumi he
deals with manipulation and many major
villains get to show off just how
specialization is but then there's poor
neglected a mission sitting there in the
corner no protagonist to sing its
Praises no antagonist to show its
terrifying potential just a man obsessed
with dodgeball carrying the entire
category on his appropriately broad
shoulders so again I think it's about
time that a mission got some of the
spotlight my only question is where is
Leorio great question because funnily
enough in this batch of chapters we are
much physically closer to leoria than we
have been throughout the entire
succession War well not the entire
succession War since the Blackwell won
departed he's currently in the medical
ward on tier 3 with both Cheadle and gel
doing all sorts of I don't know medicine
stuff so if tier 3 is going to be the
ground zero of all of the stuff
happening then I think there is a great
chance of eventually seeing Leorio and
the others having to deal with it as
well and thinking about tier 3 makes
Moreno's plan that much more brilliant
because she's chosen the direct center
of the ship starting a war here
basically cuts the ship in half tiers 1
and 2 become completely separated from
four and five will the anime ever return
so I think it's fine finally time to
start taking this question a little bit
seriously because to be clear for the
anime to come back I think the
succession will Ock does need to end or
at least have an ending within some sort
of very visible reach come here ending
come here which if Togashi and his
assistants do end up producing the
mentions 30 more chapters I think is
very possible because that would give us
a total of almost 100 chapters of
material to work with far more than you
would need for your Standard 24 episode
anime season and they would just call it
Hunter Hunter the succession contest
featuring not gone it sounds like a
dream but just like with the manga I
think that a team will be locked and
loaded as soon as it becomes viable new
hunter hunter in any medium is basically
an excuse for companies to print money
the only thing holding this Empire back
right now is togashi's back but we're
definitely getting to the point where
this could be a very real reality